hi I'm Erik Bosse and the vengers
in-game is approaching and we nerds are
frothing at the mouth with speculation
with the latest hype being will Hugh
Jackman make a cameo in the movie as a
PT Barnum right that's the rumored cameo
now of course old man Logan I'm gonna
explain why people think Wolverine could
join the Avengers and then gain and how
likely this rumor is and the various
ways the in-game could introduce the
x-men to the MCU spoiler warning in case
any of my theories are right - they ruin
your life okay a lot of this started
with a social media post by Hugh Jackman
which hey makes this our first tweet
down at Dean Jackman posted video of
himself getting shredded like every
average 50 year old does and in the
caption he included the cryptic hashtag
cameo many have speculated this cameo
could be of course an Avengers in game
because someone discovered that when you
search famous Hugh Jackman movies on
Google Avengers in game appears and on
top of that marvel head Kevin Feige just
did a red carpet interview weighing in
on the status of this murder the fact
that Marvel is as close as we may ever
get now to having access to all of the
characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years at
Marvel so crossovers gonna happen right
event rumor has it being completed as
early as March of this year so this
crossover could happen as early as
endgame but what we have seen so far is
not proof of anything
see when you search for something on
Google likes a famous Hugh Jackman
movies the search results that you see
are provided by an algorithm not a
little researcher actually checks facts
on things Google is an aggregator of
information from other places places
like Wikipedia which is also not itself
a source all of Wikipedia's information
is also aggregated from other sources
and it can be edited by anyone they
decide with the teachers than anything
they do suck but they're right to be
skeptical of Wikipedia just make sure to
check those little references at the
bottom you'll be fine in this case some
trolls edited Hugh Jackman's Wikipedia
page to lists Avengers in game among his
roles with him playing the role of what
des warlock in the post credits scene
which is especially ironic because Adam
warlock is like a perfect human being
there's no way he would hit a W instead
of an
of course eventually Wikipedia's editors
caught it and changed it but not before
a lot of fans looked a lot of dumb and
by the way just know the same kind of
thing can happen with IMDB cast listings
like a little you guys like to tweet me
hey look this person's confirmed as
being in this movie hate to break it to
you but it ain't confirmed anyone with
an account can write this stuff on IMDB
like for example in January of last year
4 months before Avengers infinity war
came out there were reports of two
Nigerian actresses being confirmed as
being an Avengers infinity war cast just
because they were listed on the movies
IMDB page but yeah both of them were
later removed it was fake now does this
mean we should completely disregard
these avengers endgame IMDB listing sad
Catherine Lankford and ty Simpkins and
actors crediting themselves as 70s
scientists know just know that they
could have been written by any dumb-dumb
with no evidence or any actor who claims
to have worked as an extra on the movie
but maybe in some flashback scene that
might end up getting deleted from the
final cut just remember Google I'm to be
Wikipedia wonderful resources but at the
end of the day aggregators not sources
in the same goes for social media don't
believe everything you see really you
can only trust it if it's from a
verified account of an actor or a crew
person on a particular project or if
it's something that I say always trust
us just because there's no evidence so
far doesn't mean the benchers end game
will not tie the Fox Marvel properties
into the MCU in fact here are four ways
I could see that happening in in-game
crossover option 1 a new villain there's
an upcoming Avengers book about dr.
Selvig and Darcy with its back cover
hinting at ain't no foe who threatens to
destroy them all you mean someone
presumably beyond Thanos also back in
that red carpet interview Feige also
talked about director Adam McKay's
comments about wanting to direct a
Silver Surfer movie have you seen Vice
cameo lacked Escambia in there did we
help them get so I look forward to
speaking with him or see in the movie
vice Adam McKay makes a joke about Dick
Cheney being Galactus devourer of worlds
Marvel actually had to sign off on McKay
using khalaqtu sin the movie which is
interesting because Galactus was
formerly a Fox Marvel property but for
fighting you to be part of that
negotiation means that Marvel Studios
might have something in the pipeline
would collect this so one way in game
could introduce this crossover is some
post credit scene that reveals the
coming of a villain being relaunched in
the MCU Galactus and Silver Surfer maybe
Doctor Doom kind the way that we saw
that tease of Thanos after the first
Avengers a new villain could necessitate
a new team of heroes to help fight him
for example the Fantastic Four which I
think we might see in Marvel phase four
before any new x-men movies just my
theory crossover option number two rad
Deadpool and it's gross but I think that
would approve of that phrasing Deadpool
is definitely the hottest Fox Marvel
property at the moment and studio execs
seem very eager to ride this wave like
last month they did that special release
of a pg-13 rated once upon a Deadpool
there were a lot of new jokes written
for it in Ryan Reynolds and one of them
hinted that Disney was one reason for
this special release perhaps to see how
marketable a less uncensored version of
Deadpool could be is there a version of
Deadpool who could actually appear at a
pg-13 Avengers or spider-man movie the
new recut once upon a temple didn't make
a ton of money compared to the
theatrical release and reviews have been
a bit more mixed but it sounds like it's
just because Deadpool fans already saw
enough of the story in the theatrical
cut and the super duper cut really I
would say if any current Fox Marvel
superhero makes a cameo and the Avengers
ending a post-credits scene I think it's
less likely to be a Hugh Jackman
Wolverine than the Merc with the mouth
heavily censored and really pissed off
about it crossover option number three
reboot and Bret Conolly x-men in the MCU
essentially this would be suggesting
mutants have been hidden around the MCU
this whole time remember in ant-man the
wasp Janet Van Dyne used some
interesting words to describe her
quantum healing powers this place
it changes you an adaptation is part of
it but some of it is evolution so saying
the word evolution is a big deal because
until now the MCU has been pretty
careful about using any genetic
vernacular because only the Fox Marvel
movies were previously allowed to
describe any super-powered individuals
as mutants the implication that quantum
energy on a subatomic level can and
higher quantities result in a mutation
could be the origin of mutant abilities
for any number of people throughout the
Marvel Cinematic Universe whom we just
haven't met yet all Avengers endgame
would have to do is to suggest that any
number of mutants could be out there and
then Feige could spend all of these for
introducing us or reintroducing us to
his favorite mutants working toward
another big team up movie
and finally crossover option number four
use time travel to merge the timelines
this I think would be the messiest and
least likely direction for Marvel to go
but if they want to keep any of the Fox
x-men actors like the same James McAvoy
Charles Xavier that we know and love
Marvel would probably have to find a way
to tie the two cinematic universes
together for it to make sense and
time-travel is one way forward backward
time travel has already been introduced
in the x-men timeline with the
consciousness displacement of Days of
Future past and cables time-travel
device and Deadpool 2 and in the MCU
time travel has been used by Doctor
Strange and it sounds like Captain
Marvel and where ant-man could have
time-travel capabilities in endgame if
the Avengers of the MCU could
time-travel back to me the young Charles
Xavier maybe as a boy at Westchester
where as a young man at Oxford or a
young Erik Lehnsherr discovering his
abilities after his time in Auschwitz
that could be one way the Avengers and
x-men timelines are both reset within
one merged timeline that way Marvel
could reboot whichever x-men actors they
wanted and retell the stories with all
the Marvel heroes in one shared universe
like they are in the comics but again
this would be a really messy direction
and really weird to plot out in a movie
so I will throw the question to you what
do you want the Avengers endgame
post-credits seem to be comment down
below with your thoughts and subscribe
the new rock stars and fall into rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars you
can follow me on twitter and instagram @
EA boss where you can see all the
cryptic clues that i like to hide in the
hash tags than my workout videos check
it out yeah
I don't hit the gym that much
[Music]